the corona virus outbreak in China
growing by thousands of cases a day well
the CDC says 15 people in the US have
now contracted the illness this morning
Chinese officials say they've confirmed
around 64,000 people have gotten sick
and roughly 1,400 have died Carter Evans
is tracking the worldwide response to
the outbreak more medical teams arrived
in China's hard-hit hube a province
Thursday as officials confirmed roughly
1,700 health workers have been infected
by coronavirus and six have died so it
is meanwhile after the Japanese
government reported in its country's
first coronavirus death Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a vowed to ensure the safety
of this summer's Tokyo Olympics in
Cambodia that country's Prime Minister
greeted passengers of a cruise liner
that began its trip last month they were
finally allowed to disembark after
several countries turn them away even
though there were no confirmed cases of
coronavirus on board we're very very
pleased to be in your country it's good
to step on land the wrists of the san
antonio public remains low and in the US
officials in texas confirmed the 15th
domestic case of the disease one of the
evacuees from Wuhan to arrive at
Lackland Air Force Base last week is now
being treated at this hospital the risk
is low for the American people but that
could change dr. Anthony Fauci with the
National Institutes of Health
specializes in prevention of infectious
diseases the message is stay calm don't
get frightened and let it influence your
life right now
well UCSD health says it's currently
treating two corona virus patients and a
third patient is under investigation
meanwhile San Diego based in novio
pharmaceuticals is one of several
countries nationwide racing to develop a
vaccine
they've already tested it on animals
human trials are set to begin early this
summer
Jericka Carter Evans thank you